[DRUM MUSIC]
PARKER KUSHIMA: Well,
it was really cold.
It was like low
40s that morning.
And I think we did
a pretty good job.
It was a struggle.
It had to go up and
down a couple of times.
And there was a lot of
maneuvering the poles around.
A thing that we all
say is like no one's
going to be like criticizing
it, whether it's perfect or not,
but it's more of like a
symbol of like us being here,
and we're celebrating
our heritage.
ZOE TOLEDO: Each fall, to mark
the starting of Native American
Heritage Month, we
raise the tipi.
The tipi is part of the
Plains Indians tribe,
and we raise it to kind
of physically symbolize
that a native
population is here.
BRIGID EHRMANTRAUT:
It's a very good way
for people to walk
past and see something
that's identifiable as
belonging to a native culture.
JAZMYN BLACKBURN:
It's very important
to celebrate the people who
share a certain identity,
especially in the United States,
that has a variety of people
of different identities.
So, it's great to dedicate
the month of November
to that cause.
And the tipi is just sort
of a symbol for all of that.
We have other events
throughout the month.
We have dinners and
speakers coming in.
So, the tipi is really just
a way to kick all of that off,
and to get the student
body excited about it.
BRIGID EHRMANTRAUT:
We have a Night
of Native Cuisine at Whitman
College Dining Hall tonight,
that we're very
excited about, where
we've been working with
the dining hall staff
to prepare various
interesting native foods.
That should be wonderful.
It's usually one of our
best-attended events.
And a lot of people
who might not otherwise
think to attend
one of our events
go to that because it
is in the dining hall
and it's open to all
Princeton students.
We have a number of
other events planned,
as well, throughout the term.
We usually have speakers
and musical events.
ZOE TOLEDO: I had always
known that I really
wanted to encourage and pursue
my culture, my community,
and I knew that, in coming to
Princeton, that this culture
and community would
be small and intimate.
My freshman year, it was Emery
Real Bird, Class of 2017,
and Chance Fletcher,
and I, Class of 2018,
we all met together and
we went to this conference
at Brown University.
And it was the Ivy Native
Council Conference.
And it was there that we saw and
we met all the native students
in the Ivy League, students who
shared similar stories as us,
similar aspirations,
similar interests.
And it was the energy
from that, that we
came back and reinstated Natives
at Princeton, previously known
as Native Americans
at Princeton.
The first thing that
we did, as a group,
was change the name to
Natives at Princeton.
And this is meant to place an
emphasis that there's not just
indigenous peoples
in the United States,
there is indigenous
First Nations,
people in South America.
So, we are all
native to somewhere.
JAZMYN BLACKBURN: There's
sort of this blanket identity
of being African American,
and that you come from Africa,
and you're black.
And that's all
very good and well,
but that completely eliminates
the native indigenous identity
of the Caribbean, that my
family is very proud of
and that I come from.
So, having this group here,
to kind of lift that up
and to celebrate that,
rather than kind of hide it
under a blanket identity,
that the United States tends
to lean towards, is really
important to me, personally,
and just sort of finding
my identity at Princeton.
PARKER KUSHIMA: It is
really, I feel like,
all encompassing, and it's
like the symbol of, it's
a home on campus
for native students,
it's a gathering place, it's
a place where people can feel
comfortable learning
about new cultures,
and it's a place where
people can feel comfortable
sharing their culture.
So, I think that,
as a symbol, it
stands as like just
our way of spreading
our culture with everyone here.
[MUSIC PLAYING]